did she just say use a salad spinner to
dry your clothes
i hope you ain't made no salads and
that's salad spinner
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been watching buzzfeed literally
since i was like a freshman in high
school
kind of known of buzzfeed kind of
haven't i used to watch a lot of
ladylike videos the only buzzfeed videos
i've watched is really like tasty
i used to watch buzzfeed a lot
especially try guys and
tasty i've really watched like the tasty
videos because i'm always hungry and
stuff
we're gen z but we're also just kind of
like not
our 90s baby we are 90s babies i don't
care
[Music]
i love the acting she's so now she said
a paper clip that would never work for
money
paper clips don't even hold paper
it's a paper clip it's meant for paper i
have no idea what this is that's a paper
clip
paperclip
they just pulling out all the office
supplies
what i don't even know what she just did
what did she just do
you know this all just seems foreign it
feels like they're speaking another
language
salad spinner what's a salad spinner
who who has that yeah who just owns a
salad spinner so i hope i ain't eating
no salads from your
bra drying salad spinner i've never seen
that either
like what's a camisole yeah i don't
think anything i've never seen anything
with
uh okay that's
okay that's smart i
don't need to do any of these because
i'm a little boy up here
so i don't even be wearing bras though
what a concept because i
am blessed with the bus that requires
one almost all the time
i don't really need these hacks but but
the last one was really smart
it reminds me of like those like super
cringy crafty videos
if you know what i mean like five minute
crafts yeah but i never thought about
like pain
how like your bra can like cut into your
shoulders i never thought about that
salad spinner
uh i don't know about that one yeah that
was gonna be like
hey mom can i use a salad
wow has anyone ever told you that you
should model oh
no no but you're so tall i'm not tall i
don't have this uh
experience no one tells me i should
model i'm average
and you're great at hugging you were
pretty much made for it
the amount of times i've been told i'm
such a good hugger yeah that's like
that's very true that's
yeah i hear this all the time like oh my
gosh you're gonna drink hugs i'm just
like
just a hug it's just average it's just
and then there's the fact that people
wear heels all the time and then efforts
look taller girls
hey hey girl really you're still taller
than me
shotgun this is so like i'mma take
shotgun
it's the way she's like the way she's
like saying this stuff like
don't talk to me i'm tall
you just let them know you are the view
period
yeah i love that one i mean it's like a
good job
i mean the video was cool like it was
cute i liked it i liked the video it was
it was pretty funny and relatable but
yeah
it was
okay so that girl is pretty tall and
like yeah
oh i really don't know what to say the
video gives me very have you seen the
tall girl yes i was gonna say that that
tall girl
movie on netflix which was low-key very
cringe it just made me laugh because
some of the quality is like
bad and for some reason though quality
things yeah it's funnier
so yeah but other than that i feel like
the video is fine
[Music]
i'm not even going to try it with this
one
exactly what i said that's their name if
you're not used to it then
get used to it take out please
yeah the name's amanda
john that's funny though that's bogus
names are a construct we don't need them
names are a construct
they are though i mean i can't really
relate to the struggles of having it but
i do
like feel you i have a really unique
name it's canuck
at restaurants my name is kay all my
friends know that
i had a pre-calc ta my guy my name is
vanessa
tell me why this man called me vanessa
every day when i have to like
tell someone how my name is pronounced
i'm like oh it like rhymes with
duck you know like connect the dark
i don't actually know how to pronounce
my name my parents named me
elise everyone says elise because i say
at least
i don't know who i am
[Applause]
this video isn't too bad very cute
intriguing if you will
compelling just big words overall i
thought they were like pretty
pretty funny but they're also like
really cringy and stuff
old buzzfeed is kind of like five minute
crafts right now
like the bra one that one was really
five minute craft buzzfeed is always
going to be
that comfort comfort channel that i
always go to
i still watch buzzfeed i mean a die hard
fan zone
you